this video is sponsored by
curiositystream and nebula and
additional content relating to this vlog
is available right now on nebula
in the last few years i made a pledge to
not fly unless absolutely necessary to
lower my carbon footprint so when i was
invited to give a talk in trondheim in
norway i was presented with an
opportunity to take an epic train
journey this video is about that trip
approximately 3 000 kilometers each way
and about what i learned along the way
okay we're packed
first trained down made it to london now
just gonna get some lunch and then it's
just after the eurostar chill day
[Music]
[Applause]
one small tube ride later and i am at
london's international train station now
i'm not suggesting that everyone does
this traveling by train is more
expensive than flying and it takes
longer than flying but the two are not
the same taking the train is a far more
enjoyable experience without the stress
of security fluids in bags or terrible
food every few hours you can stop and
explore an interesting new place
and just like that i'm in the center of
brussels now i just need to find my
hotel and i think it's one of these ones
over here made it to the hotel
which store the store
so that's the first day's worth of
traveling done
this was the really easy day like it's
two trains bus to london london to
brussels and here on in it's gonna get a
bit more interesting i've got a little
bit of time now uh it's about half past
six so i might go for a little wander
around brussels see if i can find
anything worth looking at and um get
something to eat and then i'm gonna come
back here and do some work on my talk
so one of the famous landmarks of
brussels is the statue behind me it's
the boy peeing there's some local
history which you could look up it's not
as weird as it looks honest when i think
of belgium i think of lager the other
thing i think of or at least i should
have been thinking of
is waffles so um
i found my dinner for tonight
i wouldn't normally go for something
like this but when you're in rome
i mean brussels
at first i gotta say i wasn't terribly
impressed by brussels it kind of gave me
um birmingham vibes no offense to
birmingham well kind of but it turns out
if you walk away from the train station
just a little bit then you um
i am so glad i came for this walk this
is amazing
day two good morning it is just gone
past 6am in brussels and i am going to
get my first train of the day to
cologne
don't get run over but don't run over
[Music]
6 25 6 25. there we go
[Music]
all right 6 25.
away here we go
so i've arrived here in cologne and this
is a weird one in cologne the big thing
i wanted to do is be able to see the
cathedral i was looking at google maps i
wasn't quite sure where the cathedral
was in relation to the train station
turns out
[Music]
it's right there
i can literally see it as soon as i get
off the train
[Music]
i'm just working my way through national
stereotype foods
god i love pretzels though bloody cold
this morning
[Applause]
i should bring gloves oh god i'm going
to norway why did i not bring gloves
i am really struggling to convey how
tall
and massive this cathedral is
this is a relic that is meant to contain
the bones of the three wise men the magi
that visited jesus on his birth
citation needed
i should mention by the way that i use
the rail planner app to plan out my trip
and have all the connections laid out in
one place you can even see it on a map
you use it in tandem with an inter-rail
pass and you have the qr code for the
pass in the app i'd highly recommend
getting the app even if it's just to
idly plan hypothetical journeys across
europe it's really quite fun and it
shows how easily you can get
surprisingly far
[Music]
[Music]
i'm in hamburg that was the first actual
kind of delay of the whole trip so far
this train was all of 10 minutes late
i think in the uk that would still count
as being early cool station by the way
hamburg like this
is that
really much fun
hello there are a lot of people on this
platform who also look a little bit
confused i assume because the time is
slightly different but it's got the same
train number it's going to the same
place for the same
original destination at approximately
the same time
surely
yes trains departure track 9-12 and the
metro uses ghetto by using the tunnel
from the middle of the platform
okay i have made it all the way by train
to copenhagen which is a very pleasant
nice surprisingly small train station
okay i take it back about this being a
surprisingly small station
okay so i've just checked into my room
i've always wanted to stay in a hotel
like this this is a pod hotel so instead
of having a regular room i've got well
one of these in fact this one if i
okay
and this is my room i've had to go
kneel down because it is really that
small if i turn you around
there's my little sleeping bay and it's
really cool in terms of its design you
can actually see there's like dynamic
lighting down here you've got control
for the light
usb ports to charge stuff and even a
little pad to charge your phone
there's a bit of room here for the uh
storage and stuff but yeah tiny little
room tiny little price
still really enjoying the trip i've been
enjoying being on the trains and having
an opportunity to catch up on reading i
finished a book already um i've finished
a magazine i've been listening to
podcasts i've watched a couple of
episodes of star trek i just
it's all these things that i've kind of
like built up and i finally have a
reason to sit down and actually enjoy
myself but along with that i've also
been doing work on the talk talks
basically completely finished which
means tomorrow i can just do the
finishing touches and practice it so
that's great right i'm gonna go have a
shower put everything on charge for
tomorrow and then
hit the sack i've got another train in
the morning
we just crossed the border into sweden
and it's really interesting the language
is used in the announcements originally
it was danish
danish and english and now it's i think
swedish english danish
i'm presumably later today i'll be
hearing norwegian and swedish and
english
i've got about an hour lay over here and
then i get my train to oslo something
that's just occurred to me is that
normally when you vlog in public
everyone does look at you a bit strange
which is fair enough it's quite unusual
to be out about filming yourself with a
camera but filming the trains
nobody is about an island i think it's
because everyone thinks i'm one of these
train twitchers it's just a harmless you
know harmless nerd it's like being
undercover taking the train allows you
to see the world change out the window
as i traveled from belgium into denmark
the houses started changing then going
from denmark into sweden the snow
started to appear snow we got snow
then going into norway the lakes started
freezing over i felt myself being
carried further and further north
oslo
not as cold as i feel it would be and
again gonna do have a bit further north
to go still
i put on twitter that i was gonna be in
oslo for a layover and everybody said
the thing you need to do is climb the
opera house i was like pretty sure it's
going to shut by the time i get here no
i misunderstood you don't go at the
inside of the building
you go up the outside
this has absolutely bowled me over this
is
this is beautiful
the trip this far has been really great
and i knew that it would be i'm seeing
some interesting new places and i get to
do the whole thing by train rather than
flying great
but truth be told everything up to this
point is kind of in prologue because
this is the train i've been really
looking forward to i've never done this
before
welcome to my hotel for the night it's
actually about the same size as the one
last night and i'm just i've always
wanted to do this look at this we can
change the temperature there's like the
night light option
there's a call for assistance button and
i can turn on light for
reading power socket in fact there's
gonna be two and i've already used both
uh there's a table here i've got my own
little sink
and i presume if i open this
my little window
obviously i'm gonna take the top bunk
why would i not
actually i might fall out there is a way
that can guarantee and won't fall out
look
it comes with its own harness
up here this is just so fun
right
bye how's luke
i'm turning into the night
i'm not going to say it was most
comfortable nicely i've ever had that's
looked pretty bloody well
i made it to tron time
why was it worth it
what the hell
i won't lie organizing this trip has
been
a little bit stressful
and getting here has taken a long time
but to arrive here like this
it's all absolutely worth it
is it always this beautiful in the
mornings if it's good weather
[Applause]
i had been invited to speak as part of
the trondheim science week several days
of lectures and events on all kinds of
science hosted at ntnu the university in
trondheim specifically i was giving a
90-minute lecture on the stratosphere
and why it's so awesome after several
days of practice on the train i'd say i
was pretty ready
are you all looking forward to the
lecture
thank you
okay lecture done i think that went well
how many are you happy sorry herman is
the um the man responsible for bringing
me here i'm very happy
awesome
okay
so
talk done it feels a bit strange having
spent nearly three days getting here to
be done in terms of what i actually came
here to do in
90 minutes i'm going to keep my own
phone for once you know i think it was a
pretty bloody good talk i think that was
one of the best talks i've given to say
thank you the students
hang on i've got to show you this so in
norway they have a chocolate bar called
a stratos they said
physicists love approximations so what
we're going to do is give you three of
these things
and we're going to approximate that as a
stratosphere probably the nerdiest joke
i've ever heard in my life which is
really saying something so empty and you
well done i'm also on the 17th floor
which means that the view out the window
is astonishing trondheim from everything
i've seen so far from the moment i got
off the train is absolutely gorgeous
incidentally if you're watching this and
you're a university official or a
student organization if you can pay for
my transport and accommodation i love
coming to interesting places and giving
talks like this so
if you fancy me talking about either
science communication or my research or
atmospheric science or climate
hit me up i would uh i'd love to hear
from you
okay now simon don't trip and fall and
break too expensive nice new camera
as far as views on campus go
i think this one is going to take some
beating
generally when i'm vlogging i like to
have like a storyline in mind like some
kind of structure that pushes the video
forwards
so far whilst i've been in trondheim and
i've given the talk my storyline seems
to be just pointing at different things
and saying look how pretty it is but
every five minutes i'm looking around
this town see something new and go oh
what a pretty town
so as part of the science festival i now
get to be on this side of this awesome
lecture theater
and i'm about to watch a very famous
special someone lead what sounds like a
very unique
lecture just been asked to sign this
this guitar nobody knows where this came
from
but everybody who's giving a talk has
signed it and it's uh einstein and
newton on the front i've got to say it's
amazing i just wish i knew where it was
well i wish you knew where it was from
you're gonna have to put up on the
screen when this was built but this is
the oldest bridge in trondheim and it's
very old but i don't have the exact date
to hand
i'm not exactly michael palin am i
i gave myself an extra day in tron time
because i spent so long getting here i
wanted to enjoy being here and so today
i am just going for a quick little walk
before i go back up to the university to
watch some more talks
i gotta say for any norwegians who are
watching this
i have already from the moment i arrived
in oslo already fallen in love with your
country it is so beautiful
i cannot stress enough just how peaceful
it is here
like i think in future when people ask
me to think of my happy place like a
calm place
i think it's going to be right here
before my night train i was very
generously invited to a social by the
students at ntnu i mean
being a student's a state of mind right
not an age
right
right what do i got welfare
voices
what
okay that doesn't sound so bad anymore
and no reason it's scott
yeah yeah right skull
oh that's not as bad as it could have
been
i think i'm not trying to order it again
i'm absolutely going to destroy this
i have no doubt
you all just saw me win right
now
that's the one
well that concludes my time here in
trondheim and it's just been fantastic
if you are a student and you're thinking
about studying an undergraduate in a
science subject like physics or
engineering have a look at ntmu the
experience i've had here in the town at
the university in the student society i
felt really at home
they've been really great unfortunately
however i do have to return to actual
life so i'm gonna be taking the night
train again back to oslo and then from
oslo onwards unfortunately this time i
don't actually have a cabin so i'm just
in a regular seat but um fingers crossed
i'll get a good night's sleep and i'll
see you in oslo
the train still hasn't left there are
hundreds of people on the platform and
there's two versions of every carriage
no one seems to really know what's going
on
first hiccup i've had all tripped to be
fair
made it to stockholm this is the last
new place the last new train station
i'll see on this trip which is a little
bit sad but i'm also definitely the
point possibly because i just didn't
sleep really at all last night but
i'm kind of ready to go home but i've
got to do some important stuff here in
stockholm first
some of you may be aware that for the
past few years i've been making a
podcast with my friend and human
lightbulb dan moore ostensibly about
random wikipedia articles but really
about films choral music and reading out
fanfiction it's available wherever you
get your podcasts so over the years the
wikicast has grown to a listenership of
literally dozens of people
and now i'm here in stockholm to uh
basically meet the two people that we've
entrusted with our first international
franchise this is uh greta and isabel
and um they are and yeah eric from
alaska can we can we photoshop him in
here he's obviously in alaska right now
but yeah um so they host the swedish
wiki cast which i'll include a link to
down there if you listen to swedish uh
if you can understand the language i
mean yeah i'm basically here to check in
to make sure the wiki cast the quality
isn't being diluted too much or improved
too much because part of the brand let's
face it is uh
it's definitely that it's not high
quality seeing as i was in the area i
thought i'd swing by and hang out with
greta and isabel who very generously
took time out of whatever else they do
to show me around stockholm it's like
i'm looking at two plants
so this is one of the things i was
really excited to see in stockholm this
behind me is the vasa this is a ship
that was constructed and promptly sank
in stockholm harbour in the middle of
the 17th century and it's been
phenomenally well were preserved
uh because the water here is less salty
basically in the baltic i i'm struggling
to convey this on the camera it is just
it's fast it's so cool now i should
point out that i have two connections to
ships right so
dad was in the navy and bristol is a
shipbuilding city with other unsavory
parts to his history
like this is blowing me away this is so
so
cool how well preserved and how huge
this ship is
i'm a sucker for a good model
we were just looking through one of the
exhibits by the way and somebody just
comes up to him goes
you know you look just like gratitude
which
i mean you get you must get it a lot you
do look just like her i do i do i get
that all the time
apparently you've not really been to
stockholm if you haven't been on a boat
so
that's what we're doing now we're gonna
go get some lunch
you've never shot a number
it doesn't matter how much you've shot
there will always be a shot that you
missed
i was saying earlier this feels like a
side quest in the game like i've got a
we've got to put up eight of these
things
[Music]
thank you for showing me this place
right we're going on a whistle stop tour
of the big sites in stockholm that we
haven't seen yet go
royal palace oh that's my son
city hall where friday's for future
started
nice inside the city hall and that's
where the nobel prize dinners happen up
there
stockholm verdict five stars great city
would visit again
[Laughter]
um shout out to isabel who you organized
this whole day for me yeah and my
itinerary and you found us this is like
vegan
traditional swedish food like it's
called who's most cost which means like
house house man's diet and basically
just what
you'd have in sweden
so it's like vegetables and
meatballs which is great because like
normally when i go places i can't have
the traditional kind of food so i am
really excited about this one
and this begins the voyage home today is
a slightly stressful day because
actually it's not just trains apparently
there's a bus replacement service which
um i'm not certain my interior pass
works on so fingers crossed i'm gonna be
arriving in copenhagen later today but
today's just the prelude tomorrow is a
monster monster travel day
now i'm not proposing that everyone does
this but the fact is flying is one of
the most carbon intense activities you
can engage in and for short and medium
journeys like this one you don't need to
do it in fact taking a day or two to
travel by train and see some interesting
places along the way is a far more
enjoyable way to travel
it's just gone past 7am i'm back here in
copenhagen station
and over the next 18 hours of pretty
much non-stop travel i'm gonna be taking
the train home to bath this is gonna be
a very very long day
i've got some podcasts downloaded
step one get to hamburg take another
train to the other hamburg step three
get a train to cologne pro tip make sure
this one's half an hour late just so it
stresses you out
step four have that train turn out to be
an hour late and have to run and change
trains in 60 seconds to get on your next
connection to brussels
step five get the eurostar to london
step six take a tube from king's cross
to paddington but don't film it step
seven take a gwr train from london to
bath
and then
step eight
get a taxi
home
if i had flown by my rough calculations
accounting for the fact that the route
is longer i would have emitted at least
two or three times more carbon but i
also wouldn't have felt like i'd
traveled i wouldn't have seen the
landscape change out of the window see
the ground and the lakes freeze the
further north i went and i wouldn't have
had a sense of the epic distance i'd
traveled i now actually look forward to
the act of traveling internationally and
it's because of trips like this
sometimes slow
is the way to go
while in norway i noticed something
really interesting the sheer number of
electric vehicles on the road because it
turns out that norway is by quite some
distance the electric vehicle capital of
the world and i've made a companion
video to this one about how norway ended
up in this situation and what the world
can learn from its example over on
nebula you've almost certainly heard of
nebula before it's the streaming service
owned by a huge collection of
educational youtubers including me where
we upload our videos early and
additional content such as my video on
norway and electric vehicles but also
content that wouldn't play nicely with
the youtube algorithm such as my other
video on the carbon footprint of horn
pub yeah that should throw off the
sensor as someone who watches a lot of
youtube i don't like watching ads and it
turns out neither do the other youtubers
so nebula has no ads anywhere on its
pages or in its videos instead our
business model is that you pay a
subscription that gets split up between
us creators directly supporting our work
and enabling you to enjoy an ad free
experience except you can get completely
free access to nebula if you sign up
with our partners curiosity stream
curiosity stream is of course the number
one source of documentaries on the
internet with thousands of titles for
adults and kids to choose from in
particular if you like this video you
may enjoy on the rails about iconic
country spanning railway journeys or the
charming china's last little train about
the last steam train still running an
active route in china this one's
adorable if nebula is the best of
small-scale indie content then curiosity
stream is the best of big budget
professional documentary makers meaning
it would be perfect if you could get
both of them together in a bundle which
if you go to curiositystream.com simon
clark you can do and get 26
off that means it's just 1.24 a month
for access to all of this and all of
this it's possibly the best investment
you'll ever make in your online viewing
experience and in supporting educational
video that's curiositystream.com simon
clark with thanks to curiositystream and
nebula for sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching the video
right the way through to the end i
really hope you enjoyed this one it was
a ton of fun to make this journey and
give the talk and meet up with the
swedish wikicast so i hope that you had
as much fun watching it as i had making
it huge thanks also to the people at
trondheim science week and the students
at ntnu i am incredibly jealous of the
setup you have there if i could go back
in time
i think i would actually want to do my
undergrad in physics at trondheim i i
really liked it that much definitely
check out the companion video to this
one on nebula but if you're staying here
on youtube here's some recommended
viewing next you can also sign up to
curiositystream one of these buttons
down here or subscribe to this channel
that just leads me to say please do pop
the video a like if you enjoyed it and
thank you again for watching i'll see
you in the next one